so tell us first exactly what are we
talking about here how was this cheating
done what are the details hi Betty and
so we don't exactly know how they
cheated these are not regulatory exams
these are very basic training exams that
these guys should find so easy it's
after they do they they do five weeks of
training in New York so even the the
London guys are in New York they're all
together learning about securities bonds
equities effects and then they do these
these tests at the end kind of to just
say yeah we learned we've learnt these
things we know what we're gonna do so
these tests are not supposed to be hard
at all and who are in these analysts so
I mean are we talking
these are entry-level right yes so these
are twenty twenty something's very young
you know they should be excited about
joining Goldman and they they've been at
the bank for for just months and and you
know that then they just cheat on these
tests and they they're fired basically
before joining full on so they're very
very young guys okay they're young guys
and you know what you describe in terms
of like these tests not being that hard
I mean isn't it kind of known that you
know you know with these tests these
guys you know men and women help each
other out that you know they may
exchange information maybe I mean
they're just you know they're just going
through the process of gaining into
orientation here yeah exactly they
didn't really take these these tests
really seriously and let me just say
this is not just a Goldman this happens
across Wall Street these these tests are
not really something that people find
very they didn't take them very
seriously and this this cheating has
been going on for four years it's not
the first time it's not that it was
encouraged but it wasn't really seen as
a problem so it's co-op
it's the cheating is just cooperation
between everyone taking the tests and
also you know doing the odd Google of a
question that you're not sure of that
that kind of thing right it's it wasn't
seen as a problem well it's
sounds like there's kind of a gray area
here and and what Goldman has done
apparently is is set a very strong line
and said no you know there is no gray
area you know this is unacceptable and
you're fired and given that I mean is it
surprising that Goldman has taken this
hard stance well the so the sources we
were speaking to they were very
surprised because as I said you know
analysts from last year had also done
this kind of cheating from from two
years ago had also done this kind of
cheating it wasn't seen as an issue so
they were very surprised Goldman is
obviously going really really hard on
this really cranking down so I guess the
takeaway is you know Betty
should we see this as a good thing that
Goldman is taking these tests seriously
finally and and really cracking down on
cheating or is it just a sign that you
know cheating is everywhere in Wall
Street even these tests they're supposed
to be really easy these analysts cheat
on